the British government has confirmed
plans to hold hundreds of Asylum Seekers
and migrants on a barge off the southern
coast of the UK it's designed to reduce
the cost of using hotels as temporary
accommodation and to deter new arrivals
The Vessel will accommodate about 500
men human rights groups say it is quote
cruel and inadequate the government says
living conditions will be quote basic
and functional
we can't have a situation we are
collectively spending six million pounds
a day on hotels for illegal Asylum
Seekers that can't be right I said that
I would do everything I could to stop
that and reduce the pressure on our
communities from Asylum Seekers being in
hotels and that's what we're doing we're
bringing forward alternative sites like
indeed the barge that we've announced
today that will save us money and indeed
reduce pressure on hotels all part of
our plan to stop the boats we're also
putting through Parliament a new law
which will ensure that if you arrive
here illegally you will not have the
ability to stay we will be able to
detain you and then swiftly remove you
to your own country if it's safe or a
third alternative Third Country
alternative like Rwanda
all right Paul Brennan joins us live
from London uh Paul this has been pretty
controversial already how is the
government defending this
well as your address you soon like the
Prime Minister say essentially the
bottom line is they want to try and save
money but this is the latest in a long
line of proposals none of which uh well
many of which don't actually uh progress
through to fruition we heard about plans
to house migrants on disused RAF bases
Air Force bases other plans were to use
out of season holiday camps they were
scrapped you heard him mention the plan
to take people to Rwanda and resettle
people there I can say not one person
has gone yet because of various legal
challenges and as far as this barge idea
goes it's not even here yet it's
actually in Italy at the moment and when
you ask the government when it might
arrive here many months or some months
is is the response so you can see it's
it's I wouldn't call it pie in the sky
but it's certainly not a fully fledged
plan because there are so many unknowns
about the cost whether there'll be a
legal Challenge from the local people
exactly you know how many people will
actually be able to put on this boat um
yeah it's Riven with with uh with with
well
difficulties should we say
Paul Brennan in London thank you very
much we're going to talk about these
difficulties with Steve Valdez Simons he
is the refugee and migrant rights
program director at Amnesty
International UK one of the groups that
has spoken out about this against this
uh you're joining us from London Steve
have you ever heard of anything quite
like this before
um sad to say I have a very long time
ago something
broadly similar was done by the British
government and indeed other European
governments have done things like this
although not quite in the same context
and what's very important to understand
and what makes this appalling decision
even more atrocious
is that the reason the UK is currently
experiencing an enormous backlog in its
Asylum system is for one single reason
the government has decided to stop
processing people's claims and what it
has meant is that
as people enter the Asylum system the
backlog has to get bigger because nobody
is leaving it
they've wrecked this system and indeed
the legislation that the Prime Minister
refers to is purposefully intended to
make this worse oh wait okay hold on
educate us about that how do you just
stop processing claims and how does that
help the government
well it doesn't help anyone it's
produced these enormous backlogs but how
do you stop processing claims you just
pass originally rules and now laws to
say that you won't decide the cases that
people have made and so you leave people
in this limbo they've made their claims
quite properly to you they've come
forward they've asked for you to decide
whether they are refugees and permitted
to stay or whether they don't have good
claims and whether you could take steps
to remove them and you the government
have just simply said oh no I'm not
going to bother looking at that we'll
just leave you in limbo and of course
now there are more and more people stuck
in that limbo and the cost of that gets
ever bigger well consider this the
government says that this and by this I
mean putting housing hundreds of
migrants and Asylum Seekers on a barge
will help deter other Asylum Seekers
away from the UK your thoughts
I think it's utterly for the birds
people don't make Journeys to the UK
except for basically two reasons if
they're seeking Asylum one is that they
have very strong connections here like
family so this is the place they're
quite reasonably desperate to try and
reach to have Asylum because that's
where they'll be safe with their loved
ones
alternatively they come to the UK
because they have experienced violence
and exclusion elsewhere and this is the
last place that they may seek safety
they don't come in particularly large
number the UK doesn't see very many
people seeking Asylum compared to most
other European countries let alone
countries elsewhere in the world and it
could perfectly well deal with its
system as it used to if it would only
decide the claims people make
it has been very very creative that's
the wrong word let me rephrase the UK
government seems to be going out of its
way to make headlines with its
immigration policy headline after
headline whether it's sending people to
be processed in Rwanda which still
hasn't started turning back people
crossing the channel boats at some point
you have to wonder how much of this is
political theater for the domestic
audience your thoughts on that
obviously precisely that there is good
politics to be made ministers have
concluded from stirring up suspicion
division even hatred of people seeking
Asylum that is why our home secretary
Stoops to the level of calling a
relatively small number of people
arriving on our southern coast an
invasion
it is a disgraceful way of doing
politics utterly racist and contemptible
and unfortunately all of these measures
are simply more of the same because the
government believes there is votes in
this
doesn't matter what harm it does to
people doesn't matter what cost it does
to the taxpayer doesn't matter what
wreckage it is doing to our Asylum
system and any effective means of
managing immigration
but this is what is happening
when Steve Elder Simon's at Amnesty
International UK thank you very much for
joining us today
thank you